[Music]
[Applause]
all right we've talked a lot about the
scenarios here the owners are going to
vote today we thought who better than uh
bringing in Albert Breer the Monday
Morning Quarterback who joins us on the
program Albert what kind of scenario do
you think they're going to settle on
today with the playoff structure well
first of all are we so sure that Sam
Hartman would make more money as a sixth
or seventh round pick than he will have
Notre Dame
well that's a fair point nowadays you
know what I mean like if you've seen
sixth and seventh round contracts I mean
if he can make a million dollars in nil
is the Notre Dame quarterback it might
actually be a good business decision now
too yeah you know like I I think that's
like sort of the upshot of like nil if
you're talking about the health of
College athletics is that in some of
these cases is probably a better deal
for the kids to stay in school than it
is to go pro there's like very real like
Financial incentive in some cases
um yeah they're gonna vote at noon
um and you know I I could take you
through each one of the matchups I won't
bore you with that I know people's eyes
will glaze over
um basically the way you want to look at
this is if the site of the AFC title
game is compromised by the fact that the
bills and Bengals had a no contest on
Monday then it will go to a neutral site
so if we look at it and there's a half
game you know a half game separating the
two teams in the AFC title game and that
half game would be different one way or
the other other
um if there had been a game play if the
game had been finished on Monday night
then it'll go to a neutral site the
second thing they're voting on which is
a little bit I think a little bit more
controversial is the coin flip um which
is
um if the Ravens beat the Bengals the
Bengals will still be AFC North Champs
but then after that if the Bengals and
Ravens are the 3-6 match up in the AFC
bracket which is possible certainly
possible
um then the site of that game will be
determined by coin flip because if the
Bengals had lost on Monday night and the
Ravens won out the Ravens would have won
the AFC North and had a home playoff
game
when it comes to the AFC title game
though a neutral sight do you think
that's where we're headed
possible I mean I I guess I'd kind of
give myself like an ice cream headache
going through like what it would take to
get there if we include the week 18
results right
um but you know I I so I I guess it
would be
let me think about this now if the
Chiefs win on Sunday and the bills went
on Sunday and then those two teams
that's the cleanest way to look at it
right so the Chiefs went on Sunday and
the bills are on Saturday the bills went
on Sunday and then those two teams is
the top two seeds advance to the AFC
title game and play each other in the
AFC title game which I think is
definitely possible then that's a
neutral sight game I do know one of the
sites that they've looked at is
Indianapolis
um and I can say you know Indianapolis
is incredibly prepared for these sorts
of scenarios obviously you know they
posted a Super Bowl they've hosted you
know Big Ten Title Games they've hosted
a national championship game they did
that last year it's a Convention Center
ton of hotel rooms it's also sort of
Ideal for this like if you look at the
mileage yeah from Kansas City to
Indianapolis it's right under 500 miles
and from Buffalo to Indianapolis is
right under 500 miles so we can argue
whether the game should be outdoors or
indoors since both teams play in outdoor
stadiums but you know just from a
logistical standpoint Indianapolis
probably makes the most sense what did
you make of Jim Harbaugh's quote that he
plans on
enthusiastically being at Michigan in
2023. I think he left out the qualifier
right wasn't there a qualifier in the
front of that yes he's just like no one
no one can tell the future or something
like that yeah he says as I stated in
December no one knows what the future
holds I expect that I will be
enthusiastically coaching Michigan in
2023.
um I mean look I I think Dan I I think
the best way to look at this is look at
Jim Harbaugh's history okay and when he
first got to Michigan there were NFL
teams that were hot after him right like
2015 16 17 18 there was still a lot of
interest in bringing him back to the NFL
and I think Jim had always sort of
viewed it as having unfinished business
the NFL he said it himself right and
then you know I think in 1920 that
interest in him cooled a little bit for
one reason or another and it got to the
point where I think in 20 when they
forced the pay cut on him he would have
happily gone to an NFL team to get out
of there at that point and I know there
was outgoing interest from Harbaugh's
Camp to the Jets and chargers and he was
sniffing around every NFL job
um and even last year like I think a lot
of that interest was outgoing you know
the interest in the Raiders job the
interest in the Vikings job
um his connection to quasi Adolfo mensah
who wound up being the Vikings GM helped
get him that interview in Minnesota
um you know so I think now for the first
time in a few years this interest is
going to be incoming like I think his
name has gotten a little hot again and I
think it's because there are more owners
that are leading these searches which I
think is going to have some of these
teams leaning towards wanting
experienced people
um in those jobs and those head coaching
jobs
and so that's what's so interesting
about this he's got a really good team
coming back at Michigan he's got a
program that's in better shape than it's
been probably at any point since he's
been there but coaching in college is
complicated right now and he's almost 60
years old and I think like going through
what he did the last three years
probably tested you know and and showed
him his his NFL mortality and showing
him that it's just not going to be there
whenever I want like I can't count on
two or three years from now I can just
go take another swing at it so I
certainly think that you know if if
somebody comes along with an offer
whether it's Denver with the Stanford
Connections in that building to Greg
Penner and Condoleezza Rice and John
Elway whether it's Indianapolis you know
and his connection to a top Personnel
man there and Ed Dodds and of course the
owner Jim irsay or it's Carolina with
with David tepper's resources
um you know I think there's reason to
believe in all three of those situations
there's some similarities to what he
walked into in San Francisco where
there's some Talent on the roster and
you just need to fix the quarterback
because position
and I certainly think he's going to
consider it Albert Breer the Monday
Morning Quarterback joining us
let's look at the quarterbacking
situations here I had mentioned I talked
to a league Source about don't be so
quick to say if Tom Brady leaves Tampa
and plays again that it would be Las
Vegas that Josh McDaniels might opt for
Jimmy Garoppolo and maybe there there's
not the relationship between Josh and
Tom Brady that we thought uh you know
what happened in New England and and I
was told you know Jimmy G might be a
more viable option because now you get
somebody who is younger going to be
playing longer for you instead just a a
one and done maybe with Tom Brady let me
start there Brady coming back next year
feels like it's becoming more and more a
foregone conclusion the question is
where do you see him next year
I think Vegas is an option but I think
that's going to come down to what you
just said which you know I think it's
the Raiders I think to some degree Josh
and Dave Ziegler are their GM
um I think they misjudged the roster a
little bit last year like coming in and
they went all in on it and they they
they they do the contract with Carr and
they trade for Devante Adams and they
signed Chandler Jones and so I I think
their pursuit of Brady is going to
depend on two things where they think
they are from a roster standpoint and
where Brady thinks they are from a
roster standpoint are they in a position
where they can go into a one-and-done
scenario with a quarterback if they are
then I think they go after them and I
can tell you unequivocally like this is
a fact the Raiders are looking into it
like the Raiders are looking into going
and acquiring Tom Brady
um as for so you're reporting you're
reporting that not in a place this is
something that they have and I'm not
saying they're contacting him because
that's not allowed but yes this is
something that the BR that the Raiders
have like are doing their research okay
okay
um I I same goes for Jimmy Garoppolo
they're looking at the idea of of
studying Jimmy Garoppolo and I may have
said this on your show a few weeks ago I
I've said it a couple different places
that's what Derek Carr was up against
over the last you know couple months
when when they looked at him and said ah
I don't know if it's going to work past
this year I think you know Carr was sort
of thrown into de facto competition with
Garoppolo and Brady and it's can we do
better you know what I mean like can we
is there something we can do to get more
out of that position because Carr wasn't
what they thought he would be at that
position as part of them misjudging
their roster a little bit and so
you know I I think that this is when
they when they signed um Derek Carter
that contract the idea was this is going
to be Alex Smith in Kansas City this is
going to be a guy we can compete with
for the next three four five years and
he's going to give us flexibility to go
and find the next guy which is what Alex
Smith did for the Chiefs and Andy Reed
I think Jimmy Garoppolo can be that guy
so what you're talking about like Jimmy
Garoppolo fits into that right like so
Jimmy Garoppolo could be that guy for
them
are they willing to throw that idea
overboard for a potential one-and-done
situation with Brady like that's the
question because Brady's not going to be
that guy you know if Brady comes in
you're not doing that if Brady comes in
you are loading up the roster you're
probably going and signing an offensive
lineman or two you're gonna get some
guys who are going to come in and try to
gravy train a rain a ring the same way a
lot of guys did in Tampa like like I
think that that's the reality of it so
it's like I think when you look at these
two options for the Raiders it's like a
it's a it's it's a fork in the road like
which way do you want to go do you want
to like build slowly and logically or do
you want to go all in and I think that
that's sort of the way you have to look
at the Jimmy versus Brady argument in
Vegas what's Aaron Rodgers talking about
when he says this could be my last game
at Lambeau
I think we've learned to uh understand
that that Aaron likes headlines and
Aaron likes messing with people and
Aaron doesn't mind if this stuff gets
out there a little bit I don't think he
knows though like you know what I mean
but he's got a contract
he does have a contract but I mean could
he walk away
um and retire like I think everything's
on the board with Aaron you know and I
think the right I think the Packers know
that you know what I mean like I think
the Packers know like could he decide he
wants to play somewhere else next year
what do you think the Packers would
prefer is he looking over his shoulder
is he looking over his shoulder and
saying you know what Jordan loves gotten
a little bit better like would they
offload me after this year you know I I
think like this is Aaron
like I I I think Aaron Rodgers is like
somewhat misunderstood not as not as
misunderstood as some people think but
somewhat misunderstood I I do think
there's like a little like insecurity
there like do I know I'm gonna do I do I
know how I'm gonna feel a month from now
like whether I'm gonna retire or not do
I know how the Packers are going to feel
about me versus Jordan love when they've
got to make a big decision on Jordan
love come the first week of May you know
you got to make a decision on his fifth
year option I'm sure all of these things
are going through his head especially
coming out of you know what's been you
know factually his Worst season in one
four or five years at least right like
at least since the end of the McCarthy
era so
um I think that that's what it is like I
I I I'd be surprised if Aaron Rodgers
has it made up in his head what he's
going to do after this year and I also
would be surprised if he has any
certainty on how he thinks the the
Packers are going to go forward after
this year either especially after the
Year everybody just had and maybe they
can make the most out of it you know
over the next five weeks we'll see
assess the Jets quarterback situation
next year and the Dolphins I think
quarterback situation okay I'll take
those two one at a time I I think with
the Jets um it would be malpractice not
to at least bring in competition
um I I think if you look up and down
that roster that roster is ready to
compete you know and so like if you're
Robert solo who I think's done a really
good job his first two years and sort of
changing the face of that team and you
have promising young players like Quinn
and Williams and sauce Gardner and
Garrett Wilson and Bruce Hollandale Vera
Tucker coming back from injury and then
you've got veteran players that you've
brought in like Juan Alexander and Carl
Lawson
um and and Jordan Whitehead
um and lake and Tomlinson
how can you sell the locker room on on
Zach Wilson now like think about this
right so the criticism on him coming out
of college was he doesn't he he plays
outside the structure of the offense too
much and goes for the big play too much
that hasn't changed is he a great leader
he wasn't capping at BYU we've seen that
pop up right he had The Yips his first
year they had to shut him down and bring
in his personal quarterbacks coach John
back right and then what's happened this
year so like if you're one of these
players that has so much on the line
next like like whether it's your own
individual goals financially as a player
all that stuff or you're talking about
team goals like how are you going to buy
into Zach Wilson next year I I like I
just don't know how you can so I don't
know how Robert Sala could sell Zach
Wilson to that locker room so I think at
the very least they're bringing in
competition obviously that staff has a
lot of background with Jimmy Garoppolo
um I think he's one that logically makes
some sense and there'll be other options
out there too guys like Derek Carr who
who will be out there on the market
um and then as for the Dolphins this is
fascinating because now they spent so
much last year trying to get an answer
on on tour like the owner wanted an
answer on where Tua is because they're
gonna have to make to make big decisions
on him after this year on the fifth year
option and extending him and all the
rest of it well that's why they went and
got a left tackle that's why they went
and got Tyree kill that's why they went
and hired Mike McDaniel
and now it looks like the information we
have is complete unto it let me ask you
this Dan would you would you exercise to
us fifth year option and maybe 25 or 30
million dollars fully guaranteed for
2024 right now
I'd have to know more about did you have
two or three concussions right you know
like moving forward you know I might do
a a one-year look-see but I don't want
to sign up long term for that but if you
have that like 25 million dollar number
you're talking about and you decline
that option right which again locks him
in not for next year but for the year
after so you know you're locking them in
for two years if you're not going to
pick that I wouldn't
if you're not going to pick that option
up okay now you're in a year-to-year
proposition yeah let me ask you this who
would you rather have in a year to year
proposition two or Tom Brady
I would rather I'm here I'd rather have
Tom Brady on that Dolphins team for one
year I mean and that's the thing and
like if you think about it from Brady's
perspective and I think you know San
Francisco and Vegas would be
possibilities for him but there's a real
life implication here too two of his
kids live in Miami another kid lives in
New York part of the reason why he
signed in Tampa in the first place was
because he didn't want to be that far
away from his kid in New York when the
other option was going out to Los
Angeles and playing for the Chargers so
Brady would have the opportunity
potentially to be in the backyard of for
you know with two of his kids during the
week during the season you know what I
mean like but that makes more sense than
Las Vegas does
right like so like that's the question
for Miami wouldn't that be an open if
you're the Dolphins right if you're
Chris Greer Mike McDaniel Stephen Ross
whoever right and you know you've got
connections to pray in that organization
Brady knows Ross Brady's very close
um with one of their minority owners
named Bruce Beale right if you're them
do you look at this and say we're really
close and until like two of the seasons
set went sideways like we look like we
could complete compete with Buffalo and
we went toe-to-toe with buffalo in the
snow with two in there like wouldn't you
look at that and say
this makes sense like let's go get Tom
Brady let's draft one this year so we'll
have somebody in the pipeline and
develop him and let's go and let's see
what we can do in 2023.
um I think it has to be a real
consideration if Brady shows an interest
in going there okay final minute here
Jalen hurts okay
yeah this is one of those injuries Dan
that you know I I think it can get worse
um and it just really requires rest
which is why they sat him down the last
couple of weeks and cross their fingers
that they would
um that they would that they would
clench the number one seed now you know
obviously they need to win this game to
get the number one seed and it's
important
um they're not even guaranteed of
winning the division you know if they if
they don't win the game on Sunday so
um yeah I think he'll be okay and I
think it's manageable but to get him
fully back to to where he was before the
injury
um I think it's going to require you
know more rest than he's gotten right
now so this is the thing this is the
sort of thing I think quarterbacks can
play through you know but you know the
question is like functionally will he be
okay I think they got him back to the
point where functioning he'll be
functionally he'll be fine
um you know and then you just you hope
it doesn't get worse
um while he's out there and and then you
know after the season's over he gets the
rest he needs to heal it always great to
talk to you have a great weekend thank
you Albert all right thanks Dan that's
Albert Breer the Monday Morning
Quarterback will come back with your
phone calls after this